[Aplausos]
num belo dia em 2008
estava eu a trabalhar em portugal como o
ex diretor
quando ele me faz uma pergunta patricia
conhece alguém para trabalhar na área de
estratégia de marca e de preferência
brasileiro para ir para moçambique e eu
rapidamente responde silêncio absoluto
aí veio a resposta desculpa lá patrícia
mas acho que não tem perfil para tal é
muito fofinha para falar ea áfrica e um
estímulo de força e respondi olha olha
que você está muito enganado eu sou a
pessoa mais indicada para ocupar este
cargo e foi com essa minha firmeza que
eu consegui sinal verde para avançar mas
eu lembro que eu fui pra casa todo
nervosa e tive que me acalmar porque eu
ainda tinha que conquistar a segunda
etapa que era o meu futuro boss em
moçambique
então eu decidi ir pra casa e fazer um
vídeo ea dizer o seguinte quem eu era o
que eu gostava de fazer e porque
moçambique
e foi com essa apresentação muito
simples mas com muito entusiasmo que eu
garanti a minha chegada em áfrica
fui contratada por dois anos e este ano
completo 11 anos a viver intensamente
nesta terra maravilhosa
[Aplausos]
mas tudo isso é para dizer que como é
que você apanhado muitas vezes de
surpresa e tem que apresentar sua marca
pessoal
aliás alguém é que sabe o que é uma
marca pessoal uma marca pessoal é
impressão intelectual visual e emocional
que as pessoas têm quando pensam em você
eu sou uma marca você é uma marca todos
nós juntos aqui somos uma marca a nossa
marca pessoal ela pode ser tão poderosa
que ela pode nos vender nos diferenciar
e colocarmos no patamar acima de todos
eu vou dar um exemplo de uma marca
pessoal com bastante notoriedade
josé mourinho não é grande treinador de
futebol português ele
ele tinha uma atitude até um bocado
arrogando-se confiança demais na
primeira entrevista que ele deu quando
ele foi contratado pelo chelsea ele
disse eu sou o disperso one
ele sabia muito bem o que ele queria
como ele queria ser visto onde ele
queria chegar
ele apostou e estratégias de jogadas no
inovadoras
ele apostou na sua aparência até foi
considerado sexy gol que era uma coisa
que ele nem queria mas ele sabia de uma
coisa ele queria se tornar o único no
meio futebolístico e foi isso que ele
conseguiu
já deu pra perceber o que nos torna
único
é a nossa identidade
não tem como temos que trabalhar no
nosso posicionamento temos que saber a
nossa missão em terra o que nos deixa
feliz
o que a gente porque nós somos
apaixonados pelo que é como você quer
ser lembrado pelas pessoas
depois diz nós temos três componentes
principais para trabalhar a nossa marca
pessoal
a primeira é o conhecimento
o ler pesquisar e escrever
e até mesmo escutar são algumas das
ferramentas que vai enriquecer o teu
conhecimento geral ou específico de
atuária uma pessoa conta uma pessoa
inteligente é sempre convidada para
vários momentos especiais não é quem não
gosta de ouvir histórias boas histórias
reais histórias verídicas
mas atenção à nossa marca pessoal ela
pode ser como um filme você tem que
prender o telespectador início no meio e
no fim eu vou contar uma história acho
engraçado pede engraçada pra vocês eu
quando cheguei a moçambique que tive a
oportunidade de ser convidada para fazer
a estratégia de comunicação do jornal a
verdade então eu perguntava pra toda
gente gente quem é que lhe o jornal nem
quais são seus hábitos seu costume quem
são as pessoas nunca conseguir ter uma
resposta convincente
então que eu decidir subir achou pela
que entregava o jornal e fui de maputo a
boa ne
eu passei sete horas naquela show péla
ea estrada era bem marcado e depois que
quase dez dias sem poder encostar o
bumbum uma cadeira mas feliz da vida
porque eu vi com os meus próprios olhos
quem eram as pessoas que recebiam jornal
sabe que eu descobri que a maioria delas
não sabiam nem ler e que jornal era
utilizado para outros fins
é isso
moral da história saiu da vossa zona de
conforto tenham histórias reais para
contar
isto é muito mais interessante do que
qualquer outra história
pronto e nós também temos o nosso
componente que o componente visual
não tem como negar a nossa identidade a
nossa imagem é importante eu brinco
sempre que nós somos o nosso cartão de
visita e 30 se vocês foram a uma reunião
num café no restaurante tentem se
informar se o lugar é formal se
descontraído associações positivas vão
ficar sempre na mente das pessoas e
normalmente a gente nunca tem uma
segunda chance para poder tirar aquela
negativa
por isso não pega quem nos exageros que
adivinha mais não perdem nos exageros
aquilo - é sempre mais e por último o
nosso comportamento é claro as atitudes
quem é que vamos supor que alguém
precise ir a um cardiologista e logo
quando a gente chega no consultório do
médico agente apoio médico logo na
entrada a fumar não fica bem
vamos tentar em estudar gestos né forma
de estar forma de falar de sentar
gentileza nunca é demais e você não
precisa ser rico para ser educado um bom
dia com um sorriso faz toda a diferença
para o teu dia e pra quem vai receber
como diz o escritor brasileiro do livro
gestão de imagens ele diz não adianta
fazer ioga e não cumprimentar o porteiro
neste caso guarda por isso é uma dica
que eu deixo para vocês construa o vosso
posicionar
saiba o que vocês né qual é o nosso
papel aqui na terra o que nos faz
felizes o que nos deixa apaixonado
veja os nossos objetivos é criar esse
seu posicionamento você criou esse
posicionamento
você começa a trabalhar essas três
principais componentes de uma marca e eu
vou te dar uma dica melhor ainda posso
dar uma dica tanto em dar um passo pra
fora de si
tentem se auto descobrir e faça uma
listinha dos os dez principais pontos
pontos positivos que todos nós temos e
pergunte a um amigo ao teu colega de
trabalho até mesmo em casa como é que
ele vê a tua marca atual mas nunca se
esqueçam de uma coisa nós os seres
humanos somos todos iguais porém fundo
ele as diferentes
nunca esqueçam a vossa autencidade mas
lembrem-se sempre que poderemos
apresentar sendo a melhor essência da
nossa marca carne
[Aplausos]